most people who get therapy they're
getting support there's Rapport but
Insight is not easy to arrive at and a
really good psychologist or psychiatrist
can help you arrive at Deep insights
that transform your entire life well
sometimes when I look inside and I do
this often
you know exploring who you truly are you
come to this question
do I accept once you see parts do I
accept this or do I fix this is this a
is this who you are fundamentally
and it will always be this way or is
this a problem to be fixed like for
example one of the things
especially recently but in general over
time I've discovered about myself
probably has roots in childhood probably
has roots in a lot of things as I deeply
value loyalty
maybe more than the average person and
so when there's disloyalty it can be
painful to me and so this is who I am
and so do I have to
relax a bit do I have to fix this part
or is this who you are and then there's
a million that's one like little I think
loyalty is a good thing to cling to
provided that when loyalty is broken
that it doesn't
um disrupt too many other areas of your
life but it depends also on who's
disrupting that loyalty if it's a
co-worker versus a a romantic partner
versus your exclusive romantic partner
depending on the structure of your
romantic partner life you know I mean I
have always experienced extreme
um
joy and feelings of safety and Trust in
my friendships again mostly male
friendships with female friendships do
which is only to say that they were
mostly male friendships the female
friendships have also been very loyal
um let you know so getting backstabbed
is not something I'm familiar with
um and yeah I love being crewed up you
know yeah no for sure and I'm with you
and you know you and I are very much
have the same values on this but you
know that's one little thing and then
there's many other things like I'm
extremely self-critical and you look at
my you know I look at myself as I'm
regularly very self-critical there's a
self-critical engine in my brain and I
talked to actually Paul about this I
think on the podcast quite a bit and
he's saying this is a really bad thing
like you need to fix this you need to be
able to be regularly very uh positive
about yourself and I kept disagreeing
with them no this is like who I am like
you and it seems to work don't mess with
a thing that seems to be working it's
fine like I oscillate between being
really grateful and really self-critical
but then you have to like figure out
what is it maybe is there's a deeper
root thing there's an is maybe there's
insecurity in there somewhere that's to
do with childhood and then you're trying
to prove something to somebody from your
childhood this kind of thing well a
couple things that I think are
hopefully valuable for people here one
is
um
one way to destroy your life is to spend
time trying to control your or somebody
else's past
um so much of our destructive Behavior
and thinking comes from wanting
something that we saw or did or heard
to not be true
rather than really working with that and
getting close to what it really was and
um you know sometimes those things are
even traumatic and we need to really get
close to them and and re for them to
move through us and and that you know
there are a bunch of different ways to
do that with support from others and
hopefully but sometimes on our own as
well I don't think we can rewire our
deep preferences and what we find
Despicable or joyful
I do think that
it's really a question of what allows us
peace like can you be at peace with the
fact that you're very self-critical and
enjoy that get some distance from it
have a sense of humor about it or is it
driving you in a way that's keeping you
awake at night and yeah um and forcing
you back to the table to do work in a
way that feels self-flagellating and
doesn't feel good
um you know can you get that humility
and awareness of how you're you know of
your one's flaws and I think that that
can create you know this word space
sounds very new age you like get space
from it you know you can have a sense of
humor about how how neurotic we can all
be I mean you know neurotic isn't
actually a bad term in the classic sense
of the psychologists and psychiatrists
the freudians said that you know the
best case is to be neurotic to actually
see one's own issues and work with them
whereas psychotic is the other is the
other way to be uh which is obviously
not good so I think um the question
whether or not to work on something or
to
um just accept it as part of ourselves I
think really depends if we feel like
it's holding us back or not and I I
think you're asking perhaps the most
profound question about being a human
which is you know what what do you do
with your body what do you do with your
mind I mean if you it's also a question
we started off talking about Fitness a
little bit we just for whatever reason
um you know
do I need to run an Ultra
you Marathon no I don't feel like I need
to
um David
Goggins does and it does a whole lot
more than that so that for him that's
important for me it's not important to
do that I don't think he does it just so
he can run the Ultras
um there's clearly something else in
there for him and guys like Kim Haynes
and and uh tremendous respect for for
what they do and how they do it
um
does one need to make their body more
muscular stronger more endurance more
flexibility do you need to read harder
books do you need to I think doing hard
things feels good
um I think it I know it feels good I
know that the worse I feel the worst way
to feel
is when I'm procrastinating and I don't
do something and then whenever I do
something and I complete it and I break
through that point where it was hard and
then I'm doing it at the end I actually
feel like I was infused with some sort
of
um super chemical and who knows if it's
probably a cocktail of endogenously made
chemicals but I think it is good to do
hard things but you have to be careful
not to destroy your body your mind in
the process and I think it's about
whether or not you can achieve peace can
you sleep well at night stress isn't bad
if you can sleep well at night you can
be stressed all day go go go go go go go
go and it'll optimize your focus but can
you fall asleep and stay deeply sleep at
night
um being in a hard relationship some
people say you know
that that's not good other people like
it can you be at peace in that and I
think uh we all you know I have
different RPM that you know we all kind
of idle at different RPM and
um some people are big mellow costellos
and others are kind of like you know
need more friction in order to to feel
at peace but I think ultimately what we
want is to feel at peace
I have
um been through some really low points
over the past couple years and I think
the reason could be boiled down
to the fact that I haven't been able to
find a place of peace a a place or
people or moments that give deep inner
peace
I yeah I you know
and I think you put it really
beautifully it's uh you have to figure
out given Who You Are
the various
um characteristics of your mind all the
things all the contents of the cupboards
uh how to how to get space from it and
ultimately one good representation of
that is to be able to laugh at all of it
whatever whatever's going on inside your
mind to be able to step back and just
kind of chuckle at the at the beauty and
the absurdity of the whole thing yeah
and keep going there's this beautiful uh
as I mentioned seems like every podcast
lately
um I'm a huge rancid fan mostly because
I just think Tim Armstrong's writing is
is pure poetry and whether or not you
like the music or not
um you know and he's written on music
for a lot of other people too he's not
doesn't advertise that much because he's
humble but I end up by the way I went to
a show of theirs like 20 years ago yeah
I'm going to see them in Boston in
September 18th I'm literally flying
there for for
um uh or I'll take the train up from New
York I'm gonna meet a friend of mine
named Jim thibo who's a big guy who owns
a lot of companies in skateboard
industry um we're meeting there like a
couple little kids to go see them play
amazing amazing people amazing music
music very intense very intense and but
embodies all the different emotions
that's why I love it right they have
some love songs they have some hate
songs they have some and um but you know
there's a going back to what you said I
think there's a there's a Psalm the
first song on the Indestructible album I
think it there's a
um it's sort of he's just talking about
like shock and disbelief of discovering
things about people that were close to
you and you know it's
um I won't I won't sing it but you know
nor I wouldn't dare but um but there's
this one lyric where that's really stuck
in my mind for for ever since that album
came out in 2003 which is
um you know
that nothing's what it seems so I just
sit here laughing I'm gonna keep going
on I can't get distracted there is this
piece of like you got to learn how to
push out the disturbing stuff sometimes
and go forward and I mean I remember
hearing that lyric and and then writing
it down and you know that was a time
where my undergraduate advisor who was
like a a mentor and a father to me you
know blew his head off in the bathtub
like three weeks before and then my
graduate advisor who I was working for
at that time who I loved and adored was
really like a mother to me I knew her
when she was pregnant with her two kids
died at 50. breast cancer and then my
postdoc advisor you know first day of
work at Stanford as a faculty member
sitting across the table like this from
him had a heart attack right in front of
me died of pancreatic cancer at the end
of 2017. I remember just thinking like
you know going back to that song lyric
over and over like and where people
would
um you know I haven't had many betrayals
in life I've had a few but just thinking
like we're seeing something or learning
something about something you just say
you can't believe it and I I I mentioned
that that lyric off that first song
Indestructible on that album because
it's this the emo like just the raw
emotion of like I can't believe this
what I just saw is so disturbing
but I have to just keep going forward
there are certain things that we really
do need to push not just into our
periphery but often to The Gutter and
keep going and that's a hard thing to
learn how to do but
if you're going to be functional in life
you have to and actually just to get at
this issue of do I change or do I
embrace this aspect of self
um about six months it was April
um
of this last year I did some intense
work around some things that were really
challenging to me and I did it alone and
it may have involved some medicine and I
expected to get peace through this I was
like I'm gonna let go of that and I
spent 11 hours just getting more and
more frustrated and angry about this
thing that I was trying to resolve and I
was so unbelievably disappointed that I
couldn't get that relief and I was like
what is this like this is not how this
is supposed to work
I'm supposed to be feel peace the clouds
are supposed to lift and so a week went
by
and then another half week went by and
then someone who I whose opinion I trust
very much I explained this to them
because I was getting a little concerned
like what's going on this is worse not
better and they said this is very simple
you have a giant blind spot
which is your sense of justice Andrew
and your sense of anger are linked like
an iron rod
and you need to relax it
and as they said that I felt the anger
dissipate and so there was something
that I think is it is true I have a very
strong sense of justice
and my sense of anger
then at least uh was very strongly
linked to it so it's great to have a
sense of justice right I hate to see
people wrong I absolutely do and I'm
human I'm sure I've wronged people in my
life I know I have they've told me I've
tried to apologize and reconcile where
possible still have a lot of work to do
um but
where I see Injustice it draws in my
sense of anger in a way that I think is
just eating me up and but it was only in
hearing that link that I wasn't aware of
before it was in my subconscious
obviously
um did I feel the relaxation it wasn't
there's no amount of plant medicine or
MDMA or any kind of you know chemical
you can take that's naturally just going
to dissipate what's hard for oneself it
needs if one Embraces that or if one
chooses to do it through just talk
therapy or journaling or friends or
introspection or all of the above there
needs to be an awareness of the things
that we're just not aware of so I think
the answer to your question do you
Embrace or do you fight these aspects of
self is
um I think you get in your subconscious
through good work with somebody skilled
or and sometimes that involves the tools
I just mentioned in various combinations
and you figure it out
you figure out if it's serving you
obviously it was not bringing me peace
it was undermining my my sense of
justice was undermining my sense of
peace and so in understanding this link
be now I would say that the in
understanding this link between Justice
and anger now I think it's a little bit
more of like uh
you know it's not like a Twizzler stick
bendy but it's at least it's not like an
iron Rod like you know when I see
somebody wronged I mean it used to just
like like immediately but you're able to
step back now that's like to me the
ultimate place to reach
is laughter
I just sit here laughing exactly that's
that's the lyric I like I can't believe
it so I just sit here laughing like
can't get distracted just you just at
some point but the but the problem I
think in just laughing at something like
that gives you distance
but the question is
does do you stop engaging with it at
that point like I experienced this I
mean recently I got to see how sometimes
I'll see something that's just like what
like this is crazy so I just laugh but
then I continue to engage in it and it's
taking me off of course and so there is
a place where you know I mean I get
realize this is probably a kid's show
too so I want to keep it you know
G-rated but it at some point for certain
things it makes sense to go
that